never-before-seen confidential video
given to the New York Times reveals
shocking details from the war crimes
investigation of a Navy SEAL members of
SEAL Team seven were interviewed about
the accusations against Special
Operations Chief Edward Gallagher he
faced nearly a dozen charges including
allegedly murdering a teenaged member of
Isis David Martin is at the Pentagon and
has covered the Gallagher case so David
what do these interviews show
good morning that the men said they
witnessed Gallagher stabbing a captured
an Isis fighter one of them directly
contradicting his sworn testimony in
court some of them were visibly
uncomfortable at breaking the code of
silence against a fellow SEAL dark
testimony from members of SEAL team
seven paint a chilling picture of
violence by their platoon chief the
evidence obtained by the New York Times
was part of a war crimes investigation
into Edward Gallagher a decorated Navy
SEAL who was accused of fatally stabbing
a young Isis prisoner includes
never-before-seen body cam footage in
which you see Gallagher over the limp
Isis fighters body before the camera is
switched off Corey Scott whose testimony
in court was crucial to Gallagher's
acquittal was also interviewed but on
the stand and after being given full
immunity Scott took the fall for the
boy's death they tried to frame me as a
criminal from the get-go in July
Gallagher was demoted after a military
jury convicted him of posing for a photo
with the Isis fighters corpse a navy
board also considered stripping
Gallagher of his Trident pin symbol of
his status as an elite Navy SEAL I
wanted to take his pin away and I said
last month president Trump intervene and
restored Gallagher's rank these
tough people and we're there to protect
our warfighters
a move that angered many in the Navy
including former Navy secretary Richard
Spencer who was ousted after requesting
the president not get involved in
Gallagher's case I don't think he really
understands the full definition of a war
fighter a war fighter is a profession of
arms and a profession of arms has
standards that they have to be held to
and they hold themselves to Gallagher
who just this week met with President
Trump at his moral Lago Resort has
repeatedly expressed his gratitude I
don't know how many times I thank the
president he keeps stepping in and doing
the right thing the jury heard an
attorney for a Gallagher told CBS News
the jury heard all the evidence the
prosecution's and the defense's and
acquitted every Eddie of every single
serious charge
enough said Sarika David Martin Forrest
thank you
you